so after the snap it was widely believed
and speculated that everybody who got
wiped away from existence actually went
to soul world in the comics soul world
is an actual place inside of the soul
stone in fact many characters actually
end up in the soul world but end up
making their way out of it but what if
in the MCU the souls didn't go to soul
world what if they went somewhere else
well thanks to something that we learned
from Thor we have reason to believe that
they might actually not be in Soul world
Congrats again to tiffany-smith for
being the winner of the infinity war
giveaway for the rest of you the
giveaway still continues I'm giving away
copies of infinity war Deadpool 2 and
ant-man and the wasp as well as some
special edition posters all you have to
do to enter for your chance to win is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero so
in order to dive into this theory we
have to take a look at this clip from
Thor the dark world
that's a cornfield generator isn't it
it's a solo Forge
does the soul Forge transfer molecular
energy from one place to another yes so
a couple of things stick out here in
this clip one is quantum field generator
obviously the word quantum and the next
is soul Forge so here's the thing about
Marvel Studios they plan everything out
they are strategic about everything and
nothing is done by coincidence they
introduced us to the quantum realm in
the first ant-man movie years before
Avengers 4 would come out but knowing
that it would play a crucial part in the
movie and then they realized that in
ant-man
and the wasp and in the post-credits
scene they even mentioned a time vortex
and then Kevin Feige came out and talked
about just how important the quantum
realm will be one of the most popular
theories right now is that the souls who
got wiped away from existence did not
actually go to the soul world but they
went to the quantum realm so could
Marvel actually have dropped a clue
about this all the way back years ago in
Thor the dark world
it is quite possible and it does seem
like a very large coincidence that right
after this scene
Odin talks the thort about the Infinity
stones so there's no argument that
Marvel Studios was already developing
infinity war and Avengers 4 while Thor
the dark world took place plus we were
already introduced to some Infinity
stones in other movies and we saw a nose
in the post-credits scene of The
Avengers movie so this has all been in
the works for some time now but let's
talk about how this scene from Thor goes
into the theory that the souls are
actually going to be inside of the
quantum realm and not the soul world one
fan actually lined up the snap with the
post-credits scene in ant-man and the
wasp
[Music]
you wanted a smaller quantum tunnel this
is smaller right you push sorry my dad
died
hold on line
the collection unit activates when you
decouple it it should automatically
start absorbing pons and helium
particles also make sure you stay out of
the tardigrade fields they're cute but
they'll eat you and don't get sucked
into a time vortex we won't be able to
save you okay going subatomic five four
three two I subscribe this channel
Mic Check 1 - what - pretty good where
do you go if you take a look here at the
end at ant-man inside of the quantum
realm you can see tons of orange energy
flickering and moving around well this
is widely believed now that these are
actually souls victims of the snap
entering the quantum realm now a lot of
people are saying that this is just the
energy floating around inside of the
quantum realm but if you watch the scene
when he first arrives there's not really
that much activity in the background
it's only after the snap and after
ant-man collects the healing particles
that the activity begins to go crazy so
could these be souls if we refer back to
the scene from Thor the dark world Jane
Foster talks about a quantum field and
molecular energy being transferred is
that what we see here in this
post-credit scene in ant-man and the
wasp in the quantum realm do we see
souls entering the quantum realm it
certainly does seem like a possibility
but let me know what you all think do
you think that the souls from the snap
actually went inside of the quantum
realm or do you think they went to the
soul stone or somewhere else let me know
your thoughts and theories in the
comments below and don't forget to
subscribe comment and like the video so
you can enter the giveaway and stay up
to date with everything related to
Avengers 4 as always thank you all so
much for watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]
you